puis cette autre manifestation toujours
à paris celle des algériens de france
ils protestent contre les restrictions
de voyage mis en place par le
gouvernement algérien après 15 mois de
fermeture les frontières sont rouverts
depuis mardi dernier mais l'algérie
existe entre autres un test pcr nagati
de moins de 36 heures avant le vol un
confinement de cinq jours dans un hôtel
sur place et à nouveau un test pcr à la
fin de la période de confinement est
tout cela à la charge et des citoyens
qui trouvent vers d'instruction trop
excessive écouter évident avant ça coûte
entre 300 350 mille aujourd'hui pour
ratisser 156 sa fille lourdes ou bien
ils sont pas disponibles mais quand on
rentre sur le site ya aucune place de
disponible
des agences elles sont fermées elle a
d'immenses ils ont annoncé qu'ils ont
misé sur la jante qu'on voit se fermer
pour réserver il faut aller sur le site
ou appelez depuis plusieurs jours
j'essaie d'appeler air algérie mais
aucune réponse et le terrain ça sonne
même pas et je trouve ça injuste
y a 2 bal personnel à partir de taille
vu le nombre d'algériens qui atteint
suffira jamais c'est que cela qu'on
demande des votes contestés vignes en
plus et ce ne soit pas des compagnies
parce que ça va être rude déjà que
le mois de juin il est complet mois de
juillet ils ont toujours pas de
programme
ce qu'ils ont des urgences qui peuvent
se marier ce qu'ils doivent supporter ce
qui rompt tout simplement vide revoir
leurs textes qui vont simplement dû
revoir leur famille ceux qui ont
simplement dit de se recueillir auprès
de leurs défaits de leurs de leurs
défunts